[Music]
kind of like a skater has a skateboarder
BMX has a bike I just saw the wheelchair
does something fun so why not take it
into the park I'm Erin wheels fathering
him and I ride w CM x w CM X stands for
wheelchair motocross it's you know
taking your chair into the skate park
and hitting ramps kinda the same thing
as BMX but with a wheelchair I first
started going to the skate parks when I
was eight years old and I've been doing
it for 16 years now
the wheelchair is definitely just an
extension of my body because skaters
aren't always on their skateboard and
bikers aren't always on their bike but
I'm always on my chair so that gives me
like an unfair advantage to just
practice everywhere I go I feel like I'm
lucky that I always have my wheelchair
with me because I can just jump whenever
I want I was born with spina bifida I've
had 21 surgeries throughout my life and
I spent a lot of time in the hospitals
and yeah it would be easy to just be
bummed out on that but I was for me I
just found the positive the wheelchairs
just always been fun and it's wheels
stuck to your butt how's that not a
great time
in 2008 I got the Guinness world record
for the first backflip on a wheelchair
now is that a local competition here in
Vegas called damn Jim that was a pretty
cool day one of my favorite tricks is
just simple handplant because I always
loved watching skaters do it when I was
growing up and you know watching the
pros do it it just was something I
wanted to learn I'm very blessed to be
able to do what I love what I'm
passionate about for a living
a lot of the time the wheelchair comes
with the stereotype of you can't do this
or whatever because it's a medical
device
I just always in the wheelchair is a
great opportunity Annie Londonderry is
famous for being the first woman to
bicycle around the world but there's
more to the story and the story starts
as most things do in a dark bar there is
no possible way a woman could ride a
bicycle around the world can you imagine
a woman trying to do it in a skirt every
woman could do that I'm paid $10,000 I
anni Londonderry will take that wager
[Music]
when Annie took that wager she was
losing with confidence and charisma but
here's the thing
she had never even touched a bicycle in
the late 1800s bicycles were seen as
dangerous for women and very unfeminine
riding a bicycle was a revolutionary act
legend has it she cycled from Boston to
New York City to Paris riding her bike
one-footed after an injury to India
hunting Tigers with royalty Singapore
Hong Kong getting caught up in a war in
sustaining a gunshot wound to her
shoulder Nagasaki being interned in
Japanese prison how did she get over
oceans don't worry about it
San Francisco Los Angeles Phoenix and
all the way back to Boston in exactly 15
months she did it the end well not all
that was exactly true
and you are on pewters island and Annie
was my great grand aunt
okay so then what actually happened she
was full of tall tales even her name
Annie Londonderry wasn't real her real
name was Annie Cohen and kept chatzky
she even concocted the story of the
wager and she definitely was not shot
were thrown into a prison during the
chinese-japanese war what about all that
other stuff like the leg injury
she didn't injure her leg how about
hunting for Tigers with royalty that's
false so with some true stuff and some
not so true stuff how do you view her
journey although hers was a remarkable
physical achievement a real achievement
was becoming world-famous as a symbol of
the women's liberation movement the
1890s Annie's sheer audacity and the way
she fought for herself for her own
adventures on her own terms was
remarkable for her time even if her
story was kinda sorta not totally
accurate
[Music]
how would I describe the vibe of Cascade
on a Sunday night you would see five
hundred eight hundred thousand people in
the facility you have this culture that
has been created and it's just growing
out of control and you don't really
experience that anywhere else but when
desegregation began in the late 50s and
early 60s some roller rink owners did
not take kindly to it they decided to
create themed nights specifically
targeted towards African Americans
if black roller skaters made an
appearance on other days of the week
they found themselves unwelcome
but those nights ended up turning into
something all of their own I didn't
realize the impact that a roller skating
rink has on a community they would just
open up a skating rink and boy people
came and it was always crowded so all of
those things came together to really
blow roller skating up here is what so
many people gravitate to and I didn't
realize until I actually built cascade
I don't know where I would be with that
little with skating you save me so
Sunday nights that Cascade is amazing
because of the energy we come you got
your cruise you got your single skaters
you got your couples and you're just
it's time to show out it's a real
Atlantic culture and you can kind of see
the style that Atlanta does we call it
riding in Atlanta it's just a really
cool like you ride the beat and they go
fast over the low Carrera skates with
the big speed will and you see the guys
doing the routines and they're a couple
of original groups that still skate and
they got the style started the
rollerskating culture is like a
underground family they have a facebook
we have a state book kind of addictive
it's our drug of choice and um it's a
non-stop party on wheels
I fell in love with it even on a Sunday
night we have people that are targeted
but it's getting into zero eight years
old it's kind of like the mom the dead
the teenager the little brother like and
they all are skating it's just a
lifestyle that when you come here you
get the energy of all different types of
people all different types of walks but
when they come here they are skaters so
all those things kind of bundle up into
this building that makes this place to
meet what the community was missed
if this catering wasn't here that's why
it's been here for so long and still
thriving you make it about the community
everything else just kind of falls into
place
[Music]
in the skateboarding culture you get a
lot of people in general that are
different they were just kids that want
to play someone being in their own place
and do everybody else's away Chris
Worley is the founder of a skate a
nonprofit that teaches kids with autism
how to skateboard autism has a lot of
aspects to it most of the kids need
occupational therapy of some form the
skateboarding is similar to other
therapies they're learning how to
control our body in motion and it just
stimulates parts of the brain that you
need to be stimulated in order to do
things in life in order to have
conversations in order to pay attention
I have a son who will soon be 14 his
name is Sasha and he was diagnosed with
autism at 22 months old I bought him his
first skateboard when he was right at
five years old his brother was three it
was really difficult for them to just
come together and play there was no play
somehow the movement of the skateboard
just made him focused and they would
just skate and I want to do that for
other families Chris started a skate
eight years ago in a church parking lot
in Birmingham Alabama it's since
expanded across the US and
internationally this year they were
invited to participate in the Dew Tour a
pro skating contest in California where
kids were paired with professional
skateboarders I've known Sasha since I
got involved with a skate about five
years ago the joy that I see that it
brings kids like that's where I know
that this is what I'm supposed to be
doing the skateboarding culture is
accepting of everyone to be a now
spectrum or not spectrum no one cares
what color type gender whatever it is
like if you can skate you can stay and
we got love for you it's really
incredible to see kids change through
our program I see families just see
their child who is now capable of
something
in a way forming a skate is like a love
letter to Sasha
he may never understand that or know
when I'm skating with these women I feel
on fire
I love rollerskating so much that I
decided that I was going to bring it
back for everyone i'm michelle stylin
better known as estrogen and i'm the
founder of moxie roller skates there are
21 skaters on the moxie skate team
worldwide but some of them are pigeon
Indy Jimmy Jones smelly and what Lakes
anything that's experimental or outside
of what you've probably seen on roller
skates is what we do roller skating was
really really big until I was born and
then it really kind of dropped off when
rollerblades came in roller skate
innovation just stopped
roller derby was the next new sport to
come to the roller skating industry this
meets that they were selling the roller
derby skaters were made for speed the
skates that were making now are made for
secure landings for high-flying tricks
you know a few years ago there were like
gals doing backflips and on their own
wheels and now there are and I'm amazed
at what my body can do I really am we
are chasing our dreams we're chasing
that feeling that wonderful floaty
feeling of being alive and you you will
get that from rollerskating
it's this strange new feeling that's
refreshing
ah this dress
[Music]